peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand j'en ai pour ça mais tu appelles
tu peux cran décret d'un oui
[Musique]
e
mais
nous
on
oh
non monsieur directeur jim tout de suite
[Musique]
ajustements que je bruit
j'allais vous voir entrer dans mon
bureau je redescende en deux minutes je
vais chez comptable
vous
[Musique]
j'avais peur que vous ne soyez déjà
parti vous pouvez m'accorder quelques
minutes
pardon je vais voir les aider graduée ou
à longue terme et les cas si je parle
des cordes
bon bah je vous écoute
désolé mais l'importance vous descendez
bien à bordeaux demain ce soir oui enfin
c'est ce que je voulais dire vous avez
votre conférence à l'école demain voilà
nous avons un problème et ça nous
arrangerait si vous pouviez profitez de
votre passage là-bas aux besoins en
débordant sur le week-end et même au
delà
je sors de chez le directeur
le cabinet du ministre nous pose une
sacrée école vous savez que nous avons
le dossier claude ce coût sur les reins
émile claude sco le dernier condamné à
mort comme titre la presse à sensation
d'après le cabinet il menacerait de
faire des siennes monsieur claude sco
l'administration pénitentiaire vient de
signaler que le bonhomme aurait écrit à
plusieurs correspondants son intention
de faire d'importantes déclarations
il ya aussi un journaliste de la
télévision régionale
avertie par je ne sais quelle source
la défense près semblablement qui a
évoqué cette éventualité catastrophique
monsieur je viens fanta bonjour monsieur
fontanes vient parler à cause qu il a
l'autorisation de mai sous directeur il
est en train de faire sa promenade
[Musique]
le vigile est séparée travailleurs
il est commun aux touches qu'ils y est
bien
jamais un mot plus haut que l'autre bien
même raisonnable seulement depuis
quelques temps on dort plus depuis
longtemps un mois un bon mois encore un
coup une histoire de chantage qu'il a su
voilà on a beau faire ils savent tout
je dois laisser ouvert c'est pas moi qui
fais le règlement
je m'appelle julien fontanes et
magistrats ah bon c'est pour mon dossier
alors oui réjouissez pas trop vite ici
pour vous poser quelques questions
d'ordre administratif
toutefois il n'ya rien d'officiel quand
vous le voyez je prends bonne note
bavarde que vous voulez vous asseoir aux
panneaux bien fallait rester monsieur
moi j'ai tout le temps pour être ainsi
vous avez a lancé je crois que vous
aviez quelques déclarations à faire des
vagues dans quel but mon procès pour
qu'on recommence j'ai eu droit si je
fais des déclarations mais c'est pas si
simple
tout dépend de leur importance de la
nature et la nouveauté des éléments
qu'elles contiennent sont vos avocats
qui vous ont conseillé d'agir ainsi
oh non d'abord jean n'est plus qu'un le
jeune l'autre il est mort
acier m acier il est mort voilà quatre
mois le jeune le sale année je vois pour
ainsi dire plus en tant que j'étais dans
la première page des journaux là il sans
donner oui seulement à présent
ces déclarations de quelle nature
c'est sur moi l'accident tous à
l'accident la mort d'aimé règne
s'appelait c'est un accident
quatre personnes a battu mais je n'ai
pas dans mon état normal c'est pour ça
que des accidents
aujourd'hui je vois plus plein doute
pouvait demander par tout tapage arrive
pas j'arrive moi j'ai réduit quand même
et je lis mais ce que je lis vous pouvez
demander jeudi tout pas des conneries
des livres pour lui demander si vous
voulez tout à l'heure vous disiez mes
avocats
c'est eux qui m'ont enfoncé voyant qu
est-ce qui vous permettent ça
là aussi il n'ya plus que moi en france
condamné à mort ce qu'il paraît alors il
a bien fallu dissiperait une façon pas
trop clair pour qu'il n'y ait que moi
ils en font un probablement et voilà
d'insensé vous pas et c'est là qu'on
prend et l'argent qu'est l'argent
l'argent de monsieur henri le patron
henri mais règne là où j'étais commis
l'argent que par trouver et si on n'a
pas retrouvé
et si moi je n'ai pas pris parce que je
vais pas pris monsieur mois alors faut
bien que quelqu'un cet argent n'est pas
nouveau il a été évoquée au procès je
pense bien et vous même avez reconnu le
quadruple assassinat
alors pas pour vol c'est ça qui m'a
coûté le pire à mon avis que j'ai que je
vais m'arranger pour leurs sous mais
puisque c'est pas vrai puisque j'ai
changé du tout au tout mais mon pauvre
ami s'il ya rien d'autre dans vos
déclarations vous n'avez juridiquement
aucune chance
je veux dire qu'il sera très difficile
de modifier le cours des choses
la loi exige un fait nouveau important
oui mais quoi
je ne sais pas une impossibilité un
alibi oublier un témoin on l'ignorait
c'est ça que je pour ma déclaration le
témoin en enrayant jeunes su gérer une
éventualité aussitôt qu'elle témoin
celui de l'argent que j'ai pas pris en
réfléchissant vous découvrirez peut-être
quelques arguments plus décisif de mon
côté je gagnerai votre dos si c'est ce
qu'il faut bien tout examiner
vous laissez pas influencer par les
mauvais conseilleurs même s'ils sont
très bonne foi pas de déclarations pour
l'instant il pourrait indisposer envieux
croyez moi
desmarest il a une femme chez qui j'ai
logé en arrivant à bordeaux
voilà trois ans si le forem écrire ce
serait bien mais dame andré bouix plus
un ennemi je crois aux grandes ou 34
je sais plus si j'ai le temps avant mon
train sinon je mettrais un mot vous
promets
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'avais une idée vous messieurs
à paris on n'en sait toujours un peu
plus long c'est ce que nous on croit en
tout cas il aura sa grâce ou pas
à grasse appartient seul à mon président
de la république il a souvent accordés
pas toujours
nous sommes à égalité vous et moi
qu'entre pronostics j'aimais trop
chalamet il vient pour emule ou en chef
mon journal quatre ans sa manette wii
vous êtes la personne de la chancellerie
mais je peux vous paraît un instant
voulez vous nous ouvrir le parloir bon
puisqu'on vous a informé je pense qu'on
vous a ré éclairer sur le sens de ma
démarche
il n'y a rien d'officiel je viens à
bordeaux je leur enseigne un point c'est
tout je me réjouis de l'intérêt qu'on
porte à mon client
quel qu'il soit très content de vous
voir mais je viens presque tous les
jours ah bon sentiment qu'il me voulait
mettez-vous à sa place je n'ai pas su le
sauver aux assises le départ sur la
défense non et je reste le seul et à ses
yeux je devrais passer la totalité de
mon temps à alerter la presse locale 60
cas écrire des articles et lettre à tous
les notables bas se passeront toujours
assez vous
paraît-il j'aurais aimé que nous
puissions parler plus longuement
vous rentrez à paris ce soir ou demain
au plus tard
diable mais je vais pas ma table si nous
pouvons pas voir d'un marchand mais non
si vous avez envie de chez ma voiture et
conduit les clubs sco le temps perd pas
son ensemble peut lui être plus utile
que si je le passais dans sa cellule
c'est un garçon extrêmement sensible
déconcertant vous avez fragile instable
pas bête du tout au fond mais une
timidité de la ville vous avez sans
doute remarqué son nom et son bois no et
1100 jeunes tchèques d'origine
exil du père la mine dans le nord la
galère évacuation toute la famille
descend jusqu'à pékin civile toujours
est il qu'à 15 ans non seulement il est
orphelin mais il doit se débrouiller
tout seul pour viol il est solide la
mine mais deux cases villans cesse
d'exploiter chômeurs puissent pas
facilement il accumule les procès
verbaux les mauvais rapports de police
et jusqu'aux petites peines de prison en
réalité c'est plutôt un maladroit qui
sait voir quand les autres bonnes des
coûts
vous allez à la télévision m oui j'ai
rendez vous avec un journaliste
qu'on arrête
ça vous connaissez
lorsqu'on ne jurent que par lui
c'est le malentendu forte entre thomas
rey démontrions le progrès mais
l'ignorent compétents que jean luc
renard et ses cuisses baby lisez sur son
cas non sans quelques raisons je veux
dire comment ça que le pas vu les jets
il a couvert pour employer le langage du
journalisme la tuerie de saint-thuriau
[Musique]
et
m
voici non sur les lieux mêmes où s'est
déroulée la tuerie je ne vois guère qu'à
d'autres termes employés
nous sommes dans la petite cour de la
ferme mais règne il ya moins de 24
heures ici régnait la paix et même la
fête
et puis et puis ce drame terrible
affreux qui pourquoi c'est pour obtenir
un semblant de réponse que je suis venu
sur place pour interroger ceux qui
éventuellement pourraient détenir un
élément monsieur monsieur chozeau à
messieurs choses au bon jour je crois
que c'est vous qui avait découvert le
premier le carnage il se savait en
remportant le courrier non c'est
d'ailleurs plutôt en allant au travail
parce que je croise toujours pareil mais
alors j'ai entendu hurler le chien puis
je les lui attaché au bout de sa chaîne
j'ai remarqué la porte qui était ouvert
les rideaux qui pensent à tort les
carreaux et j'ai tout de suite pensé
vous avez regardez vous avez un
processeur un pressentiment
oui c'est ça enfin quoi j'ai deviné je
suis me voir alors là qu'il spectacle
heureusement je serai j'en ai vu qu'une
parce qu'autrement si j'avais vu les
casques je crois je crois je tombé dans
les pommes ont le père la mère faisait
pas vu non j'ai vu la fille d'abord dans
le couloir et puis alors quand j'ai vu
les dégâts là les traces du feu les
carreaux cassés j'ai tout de suite pensé
à la bouteille la bouteille quelle
bouteille le bout des doigts
j'ai déjà vu la même chose moi à garosse
bouteille cas exposés mais là il ya eu
aucun mort vieille dans les clubs tous
les quatre c'est vraiment un malheur
je lèche
ce lèche vous qui travaillez également à
la ferme vous avez eu aussi cette
impression d'explosion quand vous avez
découvert la scène marcel chaud était
dans la cour je crois c'est bien ça oui
oui j'étais là contre le mur je
vomissais alors vous connaissiez bien la
famille mais règne c'était pour l'argent
quelle est votre impression crime
familiale puisque larmes qu'on a
découvert a servi pour les quatre morts
sera pas s'aimer bien
ces mets tous crimes de sadiques ou de
rôdeur
messieurs kloczko méchoui kloczko vous
travaillez également à la ferme mais
règne vous pourriez être parmi les
victimes si vous n'aviez passé la nuit à
bordeaux alors quelle est votre
impression crime de sa likoud rôdeur
voilà ce que les gens venaient enfin
pardonner je crois vous dire quand on
connaît la vérité c'est ce geste d'une
population indignée et douloureuse qui
servira de conclusion à notre témoignage
en charge de bobines
vous verrez c'est impressionnant aussi
l'après midi même il avait tout avoué
pourquoi les dévoue pourquoi aujourd'hui
vous considère l'île comme un ami un ami
disons un allié je l'aide par principe
je suis contre la peine de mort
vous savez un un chien qui a mordu on le
tube oh le tube par sécurité pour soi
pour le punir
s il arrive qu'il en réchappe et on
recommence pas forcément ouais
c'est un peu primaire tout de même on
posait la question
voilà le montage que j'avais réalisé
pour le journal du lendemain
[Applaudissements]
là
c'est effrayant effarant la loi du
talion norbourg bord la justice
expéditive de toute une population
indignée
là ça s'en venait de le voir ou plutôt
de la percevoir les mill road ce qu a
tout avoué
c'est lui qui est dans la soirée de
dimanche est assassiné toute une famille
la famille mais règne le père la mère le
fils de 24 ans la fille de 19 c'est
terrifiant et pourtant pour tout le
monde ici tellement prévisible est
presque inévitable
écoutez plutôt une brute assoyez-vous
l'après midi même il s'était battu avec
les jeunes gens s'étaient l'afp est ici
dimanche avec du pays
il a fallu deux mètres a raison eh ben
je ne savais plus moi la fin c'est
simple à voyez pas monsieur je ne suis
jamais entré ici sans qu'il y soit
jamais aurait dû 7000 ou c'est lui alors
et merde dit et pourquoi on sait pas en
[ __ ] moi je connaissais mes deux
rencontres a seulement manqué que tes
bras qu on l'avait essayée dans notre
équipe de rugby là avec son poids ça
faisait deux sacrés bourrique à la
mairie non on n'a pas pu garder non déjà
maladroit puis rendez les coups on se
faisant boire en plus arcis
quand je vais dire ça à ma femme notez
il lui faisait peur ça n'étonnera guère
pourquoi les at il peur comme ça
l'instinct
beaucoup trouvent qu'on si vous voulez
mais elle est lui trouver de la malice
une espèce de sournoiserie si vous
voulez quand nous envoyons les images
que nous avons pris ce matin de
l'assassin dont nous ignorions tout cela
culpabilité il est impossible de ne pas
donner raison à l'épousé du pompiste la
bruit était bien aussi et surtout un
effroyable simulateur
[Musique]
nous
les remarques et je pense il ne dit rien
aucun mot peut-être voulait-il tout
avoué c'est peut-être sur lui qu'il
voulait cogner tous les jurés avaient vu
cette séquence du journal
les juges l'avocat général s'en est
servi à deux reprises
c'est pour ça que je voudrais l'aider à
s'en sortir
essayer de l'aider
[Musique]
non
il
voilà la race premier donne pour les
paysans ne tardez pas trop il est très
seul le moindre signe d'amitié
tous les midis nécessaire pas facile
c'est obliger les chronos mais rien ne
vous oblige monsieur works
c'est simplement un devoir d'humanité et
où elle était maintenant que j'ai créé
mon dossier à nous ils évoquent un mal
ses adieux au delà du cas moi je veux
rien derrière l' enveloppe expéditeurs
bouëx non merde à la faire bien
s'attendait bien avec émile pourtant
pour loger ces noms même chambre sous le
toit de la grande chambre avec une vue
jusqu'au pont de pierre soit on lui
mettait une assiette il était violent a
pas du tout ou alors en paroles comme ça
la politique
marie l'excité aussi pour le faire
enrager les skis buvait comme nous du
vin dan le dimanche une bouteille de
clairette jouant cartes après midi avec
des biscuits
on avait même projeté d'acheter une
voiture ensemble une question évidemment
alors pourquoi était le parti
cause de vous ben je vais vous laisser
je préviendrai son défenseur sur votre
bon accueil
merci
[Applaudissements]
survenu bouillon non merci
tu devrais j'ai du liquide
c'est bon pour dire incluant
ce premier appareil avec poussettes et
dates de débat ce soir à 23h15 as
complèment jeu complet bombe à la
seconde complet partout premières
secondes t2 vient pas d'autre part ce
soir et demain matin au départ 1h29
d'arrivée le site aura des conflits en
côte et remercie
donnez-moi à l'aller retour première
pour sainte orieux eux mêmes dans la
matinée et non comme je dois t'y prends
c'est moi je cherche la ferme mairesse
est loin d'ici rathier encore assis
trois quarts d'heure bien j'ose il oui
bien facile
une heure plus tôt en sortant vous
prenez à gauche près de l'église vous
prenez à droite puis à gauche et c'est
le troisième chemin de terre sur la
droite
[Musique]
on
bonjour monsieur je dis un fantasme du
ministère de la justice
c'est bien la ferme mais règne ici 1
c'est à dire oui et non c'était un
mireille mais vu que j'ai acheté c'est
devenu à mon nom la ferme lèche rené
lèche ouais il me semble vous
reconnaître vous n'étiez pas avoir eu je
travaillais ici si vous êtes venus avant
vous mon arrivée j'étais commis mais je
vous ai vu sur un document d'actualité
yeah yeah voyez un document qui remonte
à l'époque mais que je me suis fait
projeter à c'est ça je comprends
[Applaudissements]
juliette monsieur vient de la justice
madame mail ou de verre dans la galerie
blum
non je vous remercie je viens de
déjeuner à bas un café et là non parce
que ça mais défendue j'en ai déjà fait
un bon pas peut être quelque chose de
doux alors voilà quelque chose de doux
pas ici monsieur
c'est assez différent de ce que
j'imaginais
avant on a fait des travaux
oui vous avez le peu que j'ai pu voir
derrière les interviewés j'avais une
idée assez vague rentrée
[Musique]
ça y est vous je vous en prie d'après
les rapports je voyais une grande
cheminée à la mairie y est toujours
ça demande du temps de monsieur henri
c'est pas ici qu'on vivait mais on a
changé d'endroit déjà d'acheter cette
maison fallait du courage alors en plus
vivre alors moi même on avait vécu tous
c'était pas possible pas possible
monsieur gaza on voulait tourner c'est
ce qui nous a permis ma femme et moi
d'acquérir à la gare d'argent l'époque
elle et moi
les familles qu'ils aient oublié de fous
où les le malheur c'est une ferme ou dit
oui parce que vous en trouvez aussi d'un
fjord pendu ya bientôt cinq ans sur
aimar de la propriété enfin tout
contrôle ou quoi
j'ai expliqué à monsieur pour nous les
débuts ici ah oui ça a été pas facile
et
et alors on a rassemblé ce qu'on a pu et
puis on a eu un ami taxe à quillan
mereilles pour les foyers les confits
c'est devenu un ami nous a aidés alors
là crédit a suivi les imiter bon on
s'est tous les poils et confie c'est la
spécialité locale je crois ah oui oui
aujourd'hui on traite presque la
demi-tonne et puis dans cinq ans
j'espère bien y arriver at à l'ennemi
alors là ça y aura une autonomie de foie
gras de foie frais oui il vous faut un
troupeau 15 cents soit au moins des gaz
automatique des prix meuse et
conserveries elle parce qu faire le
ramassage mais nous nous on élève le
produit enfin chacun son métier du monde
peut se plaindre un titre à succès l'un
non merci sam et sociaux à ses meilleurs
moyens de les voir à côté
[Musique]
à
mais non
[Musique]
on
de l'est sans doute à à huy d'abord ça a
été par obligation mais puis s'étaient
tous y avait pas d'héritier voyez c'est
bizarre ça aucun héritier
ça a été vendu par les domaines pour les
impôts puis les dates ici en tout cas
personne n'a occupé pendant des mois et
bien des curieux de partout et même
quand l'idée dé vue d'acheter j'ai dû
surveiller un les gens partent avec des
morceaux ouais les assiettes des corps
après je voulais toujours approprié même
âge est ce que mamie qui nous a fait le
prêt d'argent ici en temps en affaires
il m'a déconseillé l'aise dedans qui m'a
dit tant qu'il reviendra voir c'est
toujours une bonne publicité pour toi
j'ai écouté même je ne prends bien
[Musique]
mme angèle à tous
le patron en bout son fils à sa droite
claude mademoiselle en face de lui et la
patronne d'un côté souvent debout la
pauvre est la physique et puis moelle
[Musique]
[Rires]
émile ce couillon
[Musique]
ici
en bout de table car cela cause est pour
ainsi dire toute manière
quand on se connaît beaucoup raconté
quoi le travail
comme référent l'avait fait en ce moment
là pourquoi en parler la mise peu après
il a toujours dit non mais nous on pense
que oui si henry il est tombé là il a
pris dans la poitrine il a glissé sur
son cul à pattes on a basculé puis
monsieur claude chossat j'ai vu les
photos avant
mais il y avait eu des scènes entre déjà
des disputes des colères alors jamais au
contraire à penser long il se plaisait
les villes
c'est à se demander ce qu'il est pour
moi voyez si la boisson
ouais c'était devenu énorme ce qu'ils
buvaient la faim énorme et au début
[Musique]
normal et même pour la région plutôt
moins que la normale parce qu'il faisait
un drôle de boulot vous savez était
parfaitement les mille ouvriers
c'est moins gênant à dire maintenant
qu'ils sont morts mais
les patrons les exagérer avec lui trop
de vin travail
même là dimanche au iv
et une clôture à les redresser ou jus
c'est des pierres à mettre dans les
trous au bout du chemin allez c'est la
tienne à ok
et bill quand je pars chez moi là je
reviendrai demain ça ne serait ce pas
surtout si tu es fini trop tôt quand on
me ruby il claude ouais j'aime bien moi
à l'évent quant à démolir ou bien le
contraire
solide milou havrais cou de taureau
je commence à connaître tu sais et
surtout je vois ce qui frappe je
commence à les voir alors eux aussi ils
vont voir
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi lui plus que les autres
pourquoi pas du coin d'abord même
étranger en plus puis les tétons sûr de
sa force il provoquait un peu peu
beaucoup même voulait qu'on le remarque
qu'on s'intéresse à lui d'une manière ou
d'une autre les gens profitaient riz
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
m
alé lô
[Applaudissements]
je sais rien
je paye d'accord entendu nous aimons
bien l'oréal
l'amitié au vainqueur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas malheureux dans l'ariège et sa
femme camilla n'ont pris qu'un point que
je paye mes week apportons voulait pas
sortir dehors et les âmes il a besoin
d'air d'abord les sorties de moi
j'aimerais aussi voir ça fait marcher le
commerce l'appellation de le faire une
drôle de façon de faire marcher le
commerce pour les toits rené de la ferme
c'était plus
qu'est ce qui se passe ici comme evans
bruit en arrivant là alors on l'a si
elle moi allez on va le ramener il faut
être adaptée du docteur mon bon bilou le
toubib
ben merde oui même pas le vétérinaire
prenez vous ne suivez ce jour là je m'en
suis volet n'aurait pu en claquer mais
allez le retenir et l envoi de la fête
il aurait lui aussi bien des vitriol du
reste si on avait claqué et oui ce n'est
pas plus mal
ce que vous voulez dire personne ne
choisit complètement son destin pour les
merengues
en tout cas il aurait mieux valu
effectivement qui va en claque
il ya un point sur lequel vous pourriez
matin précieux secours c'est l'argent
et vous quel argent je veux parler si je
sais l'argent de la boîte en fer 1
qu'est ce que kate moss a dit henry
était juste pris dedans avec l'argent à
la ferme on le savait mais pas seulement
à la ferme
vous savez dans les affaires souvent on
s'arrange on prend un peu en chèques et
puis un bon plan les guides si c'est
possible
j'aurais peut-être pas de vous dire ça
monsieur lignes aériennes support le
fisc ouais bref il avait un coffre à la
banque mais souventes fois il se gardait
des liasses dans une boîte en fer une
boîte à biscuits qui traînait là du
buffet et puis comme ils l'on puisse
laisser jamais gagnée par la soif ben il
ya des fois c'est inquiétant de le voir
ouvrir cette boîte devant n'importe qui
pour rendre la monnaie où vous prenez
atteint parce qu'il mettait aussi les
dames de dans la folie sans compter
qu'ils avaient des millions parfois ces
millions j'ai vu trois millions - dans
cette boîte jour du crime au moins deux
il était passé un homme d'un grand
restaurant de paris la veille puis sané
1 qui avait une grosse pincée sous la
table à tous les coups croyez moi et
puis le matin magescq était venu à la
fête en même temps qui réglait sa note
maj est ce que c'est vos premiers des
programmes season grossistes à dax poids
grèzes confie enfin berlin c'est
exactement la somme il me l'a dit neuf
cent mille centimes
vous allez voir que 2 millions en
dessous et d'une belle somme encore on
n'a rien retrouvé tout et seulement
vous allez comprendre la boîte mais des
tombes est ouverte
là c'est également ce bouteille partie
par terre on a piétiné tout ça pendant
des heures les billets en voile et
monsieur ensemble voilà où ils sont le
passé les billets avec le feu ouf
mais si ça se trouve ça il ya les avoirs
vous aviez un centimètre de suie mais
enfin il n'y a pas eu une analyse au
bien sûr mais pour les gens ce qu on a
pas trouvé c'est d'elias vous voyez les
cendres avec toutes les analyses que
vous mettrez de ceux qui s'en foutent
les gens des liasses c'est que moi j'en
ai entendu vous savez oui au pas les
gendarmes
les gendarmes les analyses ils font
confiance les jaloux les pros besoin de
lui qu'on a été à l'école a vécu
l'ancien comique qui rachète la ferme
fait que le magot un patient semble que
ça le magot les couillons si votre thèse
est la bonne et je le crois
pas de témoins miraculeux et bien sûr le
vol n'est plus le mobile du crime
à moins que à moins qu'il ait été
surpris cherchant à s'emparer de la
cagnotte
non toute la famille était là moi je les
ai quittés peut-être dix minutes avant
lui avant la boucherie c'était la fête
vous savez la patronne avait mis un
fagot dans la cheminée pour faire
griller les saucisses je vous dis la
fête sur ce qui s'est passé vraiment il
en reste qu'un de bon monsieur
un seul est peut-être plus pour
longtemps
[Musique]
avant elle
j'ai vu en vitrine la pochette de la
salomé de strauss nous laver en magasin
quand je gardais de risque en tout cas
j'ai des vaccins non richard strauss
j'essaie d'avoir chez mon disquaire
pendant philharmonique de vienne avec le
garde behrendt je suis pas un four à
regarder et vous n'avez rien d'autre
c'est d'artistes sine qua violoniste non
c'était une chanteuse lyrique
bah vous me dites strauss trop ce qu'est
le viol au 1
la pile et de l'avant vous n'avez qu'à
regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
aujourd'hui monsieur c'est vous aurez
mille vous examinez raison pour que nous
apportions pour des problèmes
franchement tous les deux je reviens de
saintes orieux j'ai vu des gens là bas
j'ai surtout vu rhône et lèche c'est un
garçon intelligent droit qui ne vous
accable pas rené je me doute c'est un
bon coeur rené vous savez qu'il a acheté
la ferme
oui ça a été dans les journaux ou du
courage à dieu je suis passé également
la gendarmerie et j'ai rencontré
quelques autres personnes dont le moins
qu'on puisse dire est qu'elle nous
faisons guère compatissante
ah bon écoutez 1000
dans l'air
je me suis également rendu au studio de
la télévision vous avez trouvé jean luc
pomarède
celui là il est vraiment de mon côté ça
lui il a un ami un il a pas pu vous dire
de mal sur moi j'en suis sûr nay années
à venir même entrer les bouts de fil et
croyez-moi il a mieux valu pour vous qui
ne les prenne jamais votre ami pomarède
mais monsieur c'est son métier il m'a
expliqué j'essaie lettres l'événement la
commander et depuis il n'arrête pas de
faire ce qu'il peut pour me sauver la
vérité qui ne peut pas grand-chose à
rester assise ou m'agacer je dois m'y
prendre avec vous comme avec un grand
malade
un enfant auquel on doit annoncer de
mauvaises nouvelles faudrait que j'ai un
coach de pièces que je vous rassure je
ne peux pas rassuré
ça va très mal pour vous pour prétendues
déclarations
si vous pouvez rien me dire d'autre ne
contiennent pas eu nombre d'arguments de
révision pas même une trace capable de
déclencher une manoeuvre suspensives
je vous dis la vérité parce que
j'attends de vous la vérité mais comme
rien justement la vérité ça rende pas la
vérité elle est comme elle est on oublié
votre témoin fantôme l'homme qui aurait
pris l'argent mais puisque c'est pas moi
qu'il fallait bien qu'ils passent par là
celui qu'il a dérobé
aimer
il n'ya plus que la grâce présidentielle
on ne reprendra pas votre dossier on ne
refera pas votre procès or beaucoup de
choses nous sont favorables
certaines déclarations officielles
l'opinion publique y évoluent la cour de
cassation est intervenu à plusieurs
reprises comme une juridiction d'appel
des assises tout ça est plutôt bon comme
climat mai et la décision dépendra d'un
homme seul
cet homme sera presque disposera pour se
prononcer des conclusions d'une
commission spéciale et il n'aura se
justifier devant personne
puis il aura peut-être un petit peu de
rapports que je vais être obligé de
faire un bon tour mais commission
spéciale a déjà examiné votre dossier
moi j'ai rien écrit émile je suis votre
dernier recours avant le président
vous avez anéanti une famille de quatre
personnes c'était ivre un jury vous a
condamné à subir la peine capitale
croyez vous faire la place du cheval
comme eux j'ai sûrement pensé plus que
vous à ce que j'aurais fait j'aurais dit
oui la coupable
et oui à tout ce qui est contre moi
aujourd'hui c'est vrai ce ne pas dire
j'aurais eu raison
du côté gauche il n'y a plus grand monde
je suis même le dernier à ce qu'il
paraît alors les choses que j'ai
apprises
ce que je sais comment vous expliquer
aujourd'hui je voudrais pas comme eux
voilà je vous le dis sincèrement
je les aimais bien moins aimé règne
personne ne pouvait en dire de mal
devant moi
[Musique]
je vous avais bien
surtout jacky la demoiselle
elle aussi je croyais que
je me suis trompé avec tout sur eux
tout dunant
petite jackie quand elle vous regarder
dans les yeux c'était tout droit tout
net fait qu une espèce d'amitié
alors moi je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ou aux pays bas
qu'est ce que t'as foutu mon dieu j'ai
foutu qu'il a fallu décharger qui n'ont
fait goûter au gâteau est ce que tu
racontes et un jacky tu donnes est-ce
que j'ai gagnée aux tirs aux tirs je
suis passé au milieu de la fête
un jeu pas de stream retenir deux pipes
et les petites fleurs que je lui ai
apporté mon [ __ ] voici la attendre
dans des chaussures qui me passent de
partout et toi tu commences tu as fait
ta merde alors c'est un but deux minutes
patron c'est rigolo c'est une fleur en
papier plus tôt fait plaisir est battu
c'est ce qui va me faire plaisir en
attendant que retourne à cette sacrée
putasserie de carnaval
ça va être que tu racontes mode le
moteur de la pompe de l'évier parce que
la patronne elle a plus d'eau mais moi
je suis trop propre pour me [ __ ] dans
le camp bruit mes patrons star exemple
prendre un motif mon après midi en date
et expliquera que la mère georgette mon
vieux mois
[Applaudissements]
m
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
je vais vous dire la patronne pour bien
parler avec monsieur henry avant d'aller
voir cette fête qui est pas là il fait
sa sieste à vous laver les places et qui
vous empêche qu yvan pêche c'est
seulement les jambes et à la curée à 4
heures que s'ils n'ont pas leur taxe
n'entrerait parler toute l'année
l'an dernier j'ai fait quatre cartes ça
n'a pas plu et fils qui nous ramènera
des copains dans la soirée pour briller
à saucisse et la soupe
elle se fera tout seul un jour comme
aujourd'hui l'assaut pouvons saurait
sans pinceau et ben pas lui voyez où
émile il ne peut se passer dit soutenu
sieste qu'est-ce que tu râles encore te
voilà déjà ces bruits vos sorts lui
attraper sur les canalisations tutoie
les jacks inscrits
j'ai discuté avec rooney n'est pas
dérangé ton lit j'ai dit oui pour ce
qu'ils voulaient ce déraisonnable
juste un but de ce qu'on pensait je me
doute de quoi vous parliez patron alors
moi aussi je voudrais bien né sera pas
réveillé ce corps et l'a vite séjour ou
jamais son constat aujourd'hui vous
allez me donner une même pris pour
l'année prochaine
je connais la coutume le salaire se
discute aujourd'hui on avancera c'est
les idées par mois patron puisqu'on est
sur la question je vous dis ce que je
veux vous c'est oui ou c'est non je me
sauve ça les empêche
tu peux bien me dire ce que tu veux
entre deux gorgées
non je vous dis pas de boisson
et pas bon
alors combien du vote plus parce que
j'ai pas de plus ce que je vais aussi
s'est couché dans la maison c'est ça la
différence dans la maison pardon tu veux
coucher tout seul ou bien avec moi ou
avec la patronne ou alors si je te gêne
je peux mandat les halons patron une
qu'est ce que vous racontez ac plutôt
doit il me semble ce que je veux c'est
un coin à moi qui ferment et où je vais
te mettre à cannes 1 6 et ça vous avez
au moins 2 charlot rien faire qui
connaît la maison dit donc celle de rené
avant qu'ils se marient et l'une est
celle de claude silva travail à bayonne
bayonne d'abord s'est pas fait celle de
rené ensuite on y met des chiffons
déconfiture jean délavé payer son loyer
demande bien sûr c'est normal aussi je
le paie puisque vous mentez pas tu
l'entends
il est comme un notaire celui-là avec
les sous c'est juste patron la
différence que j'aurais pu vous la
gardez comme loyer et si je dis non je
m'en vais
eh ben mon [ __ ] c'est le couteau sous
le quai king tut nous mais rien n'aurait
pas une idée derrière la tête par hasard
à vouloir tellement entré dans la maison
ou du crois que j'ai mes yeux des
petites mines que tu lui fais biel qui
commence à te rendre joue pas l'innocent
avec moi émile vignes apreva jacky pour
sow tu peux donc pas attendre ya rien à
attendre
y'a pas de sambre ya pas de jacky et si
ça lui convient plus toile a pas trop de
savoir quand je dors tu discutes pour
moi quand jean plus bon peux pas te
laisser monter là haut c'est trop de
risques un deux ou trois ans il
déciderait pour toi j'ai rien à dire
majeur à l'ancienne je me tais puis
d'ailleurs ne faisons plus comment veux
tu que je te augmente de ce moment et
mais tu vois les prix tu vois comment
tout se passe quoi dre truc que tu
achètes cela tombait raide
non ce que je peux faire c'est s'est
installé à linars mois dans le bout du
petit bâtiment porte avec serrure clé
puis je te donne quatre sacs de ciment
couler une dalle pour faire plus propre
tellement donné dimanche d'un mois pour
compenser à rentrer le bois de
montgeroult mon idée c'est dans la
maison comme était rené chevaux comme
lui
on va disputer sa vieux jugement divin
qu'est ce que tu vas fabriquer des
regards du tout bon dieu c'est entre
nous et bill et moi je connais sopalin
tu vas bien des causes et en bon c'est
bien la tchaux de l'autre cinq
cartouches
elle distance chaque bouteille ou l'aco
si tu gagnes je te donne ta chambre
si je gagne et battue reste tout est
régulier énorme
je vais vous avoir là je suis bon il est
barré jg
[Musique]
on
tout de même patron ce que vous disiez
au sujet de la petite c'est pas bien
j'en rien essayé je vous jure je vais
pas dit que ça vienne de toi emile qui
allez arrête de m'amuser montre ta
science
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà crête et 5 lui dit d'aller plus
loin va il déménagera une autre année
mon gars ça ira mieux à la fête à 3
mètres tu toucheras peut-être une grosse
assiette est alors gros con pour être
payés plus
mais quel besoin tu as d'aller parler de
jacky comme tu le fais pas plus rire des
fois
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
bien sûr tu vois pas quel concours
jewel gagné par mois tu choisis là
dedans avais tu marianne beau nick bon
et moi je ne suis ni boniments aaa
est-ce que je me sers à j'avais encore
encore encore encore encore stop ça va
on se comprend mais deux hatier nature n
est pas attention
[Musique]
votre as de trèfle je vois mal engagé
mais pas en quoi mais c'est un scandale
aux jeunes en de l'annulation de la
partie orale de fer nouveau annulé la
partie l'on n'est pas question on met le
coup mais pas la partie finale du
problème pour commencer un c'est la fête
et vous êtes en train de faire des
figures de fait sans toi moi je ne joue
plus énormes alors commencer je refuse
de reprendre la partie tant que chaîne
moche qui restera dans mon dos ils ont
en fait c'est pareil et une foule a
permis au mouvement
[Musique]
aller à ma santé vous allez voir
ailleurs ou les dérangements que lance
bille fut ni mon frère ni son copain
avec moi
[Musique]
paris
le ch renforça pense plus
[Musique]
il
on va pas danser comme ça entre page
interdite par les droits de l'homme
tétouan vie je sais vous aimez
et avec moi voulait pas essayer
régal
il
mais
[Musique]
et
oh
[Musique]
et
tout en fruit m c'est un choc
[Musique]
et
qu'on va pas se quitter après la
première bouchée j'ai droit celle qui
vient hockey pendant la demoiselle
merci pour lui je n'ai
liban tapine et amusé hervé second
semestre
m
[Musique]
et
je causais avec votre père à antony
[Musique]
ma vie drôles de choses mais ferrari à
cassis jeux wii
dans c'est pas mal
c'est vrai que le patron été commis chez
les parents de la patronne rond qu'il se
marie s'est trouvé à redire au nom
contraire on mène ça bien c'est comme
nous offrons
pareil que nous
j'attendrai moi je suis vous étiez
d'accord de toute manière monsieur henri
les plus tôt pour passion à ce qu a dit
toute la patience que vous voulez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
non
celle qui sépare dollars et comprend ce
que staline vous devriez toi tu parles
encore un passeur comme tu viens de le
faire tu pourras chercher du boulot
ailleurs
pauvre à vos dit vous devriez pas rire
de moi tous comme ça surtout la
demoiselle
je suis dans ma bulle moi je crois qu'il
a compris bas mi temps verra plus
maintenant avec ce qu'il a pris toi tu
seras l'hôpital arnaud lavage
tu le laissera tranquille à la maison
pourquoi soit parce qu'ils me fait un
peu peur maintenant
[Musique]
si c'est pas malheureux
demain alors à tourner mais il va rester
avec nous relaie nokia droit compagne et
non non non non pas question
j'ai vu ce fait un saut pour vous
apporter d'armagnac mais je m'en vais
enfin le matin as tu vois mais on rate
la bouffe est associée [ __ ] dire et on
pas il est à 35 tu dis on y va fort taux
père et vous en trouverez plus de la
comm ca pas ton et puis aux étrangers la
bande le triple les étrangers les
étrangers bon bah ça doit faire 210
c'est bien ça situe à 35 c les
différents que c'est pas trouvé moi
voilà genoux les musiques comme il faut
sa famille n'est pas ton père alex qui
l'emplît fait toute la journée
souvent senti prêt je doute qu'elle bien
moi la patron de sol et 10 217 euros
si on voit ça goûte et ou belges à n'en
pas moins tendre là je la connais assez
celle là alors je me sauve boudina
juliette matin mais nous travail atone
non non non non pas pour moi jeunes ont
alors jeté la vraie belle rétros rouges
patronne lui les verts venez vous pouvez
plus partie allait voir si je peux voir
partie aller a lieu à tous
robert et servir des eaux
un visiteur qui s'amène là il n'est pas
perdu mon verre bonne toute bonne dit
donc pas au sujet des mises
on me donnait ma patron je m'en veuille
tu t'en vas où ça ou ça me plaît d'abord
tu appelles c'est pas le jour c'était le
jour et si vous ne donnez pas je ne
voudrais pas notre servi alors alors
aimer le on va l'avoir très qui avait
avec personne ici pour moi vous n'êtes
que des chiens à tous non mais dis donc
si c'est comme ça d'abord tu peux pas
partir illégalement tu peux pas donner
moi mon argent et on va voir mais
monsieur emile avec tout le travail que
nous avons de retard monsieur emile bon
dieu c'est nouveau ça et vous
n'oublierez pas les quatre centres au
budget du mois dernier
iran gendarmes pour ça et ça paye
tu peux toujours rêver créateurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après je sais plus je n'ai jamais
retrouvé ce que j'avais fait le matin il
me semble que j'ai essayé d'éteindre le
feu j'ai dû marcher aussi
je n'ai jamais autant dit je crois ça
m'a soulagé
ce qui m'arrive monsieur dans le fond
après ce que j'ai commis c'est rien
ça ramène rare aucun des pauvres mort
que j'ai fait mais je veux plus réclamé
aujourd'hui je vois clair c'est juste
je mérite rien mieux non
je dois rencontrer votre avocat m'invite
à passer le voir avant mon train je vais
m'informer auprès du procureur qui a
requis contre souffre à votre idée mais
tenez
c'est très beau frère comment voulez
vous que plus tard et coûterait plus
tard
ce que je ne parviens pas à comprendre
et je vous dis la chose un peu du roman
comme elle me vient c'est l'absence de
combat de la défense sont à vue le
sentiment à parcourant les extraits de
presse que j'ai pu obtenir maîtres
saverdun que j'ai eu au téléphone m'a
confirmé dans cette idée du billard sont
ses propres mots j'ai gagné par k o la
formule est assez inélégante danier la
vie d'un homme n'est pas un loup en ce
sens il y avait une possibilité très
réelle d'arracher les circonstances
atténuantes les mairies avait été
imprudent
je pense à l'argent dont ils se sont
servis pour exploiter claude ce qu est l
leur ironie assez méchante de composants
d'un mélange bien explosif et puis il ya
ce fusil qui hélas au fusil d'un modèle
a encore chargé de quatre cartouches le
suicide mais muet refusé car il manque
la cinquième tir et dans l'après-midi
alors on joue sur des coïncidences aussi
tragiquement exceptionnel on montre la
menace du groupe même s'il n'y a pas
matière à évoquer la légitime défense
on exploite tout ce qui peut l'être on
ruse on triche quand on défend
imaginez un florio un garçon à paulhac
sur ce dossier un imaginaire imaginez
vous même cette cour provinciale
les jurés qui sont des régionaux
fermiers ou parents de fermiers pour la
plupart le défilé des témoignages
accablants claude ce correspondant qui
paraît jouer une comédie qui ont fait
trop et détruit par cette attitude toute
la force des éléments que vous évoquez
la menace la tentative de suicide
l'argent consumer car personne ne peut
confirmer ses déclarations il est le
seul survivant est l'assassin comment le
croire
comment prouver sa sincérité or
nécessaire en tout cas on tente
l'impossible j'ai souvenir d'un mètre
asseyez combatif redoutable
il était mort pardon
si cette confidence peut servir claude
sco
vous avez raison le dossier a été mal
plaidé
plus tôt il ne l'a pas été
nous étions convenus mon maître et moi
de laisser passer les témoignages disons
de ragots sans intervenir
mais deux dépositions nous paraissait
fondamentale celle d'abord de rené lèche
parce qu'ils connaissaient tous les
protagonistes du drame et sans l'excuser
rester favorable à claude ce qu il fut
parfait et le jury perdit de son
hostilité compris 1000 celle ensuite
d'un certain paul bru est accablant pour
notre client qui l'accusait d'avoir
menacé jacquier claude et même de les
avoir suivies au sortir du bal alors
qu'il était parti depuis longtemps roué
de coups il nous était facile de le
convaincre de mensonges j'attendais
l'intervention de m rien
la défense at-elle quelques questions à
poser aux témoins
[Musique]
pas de question j'étais atterré nous
étions l'un en face de l'autre des
jeunes et m dassier comme absente se
taisait je croyais préoccupés par notre
défaillance du matin calculant une
manoeuvre ebit hélium à canal hitler à
votre avis épithélioma canal hitler une
fleur à papillons ni la maison ou
peut-être
l'année l'ont en tout cas c'est ce que
j'ai en clair on peut traduire aussi
concert du pancréas j'ai su ce matin
quand j'ai téléphoné un couturier m
vous savez mon ami le professeur
couturier territoire de la vérité toute
la vérité rien
[Musique]
j'en ai tout entre deux
huit mois j m
déploiement jeu peu cramé ici je
monologue tjp souffrir terroristes
portons pour claude ce cause ce matin je
le sais j'étais moche si on va faire
revenir le témoin je rattrapais
toussaint je ne suis pas fini tu vas
voir tous rattrapés comme animons 62
voyez tout ce que j'étais fou de cette
fois il n'a rien rappelé du tout il est
bien foutu
mais pourquoi me racontez vous
s'allonger à fontanes c'est navrant mais
dépourvu de tout intérêt juridique
je le sais je ne sais que trop claude
sco ne fera aucune déclaration avant
de toute manière est absolument aucun
élément nouveau qui puisse surgir en
dernière minute est juridiquement nous
mais tend les bras
nous sommes d'enfants d akoupé le coup
d'une boîte nommée emile trotsko qui a
sauvagement assassiné les quatre membres
d'une même famille à 18 mois le jury
populaire se prononcer pour la peine
capitale à l'issue d'un procès correct
dans ses formes
mais vous avez exécuté un autre un autre
emilie claude com et vous aurez à tenir
compte de ce qui n'a jamais été
normalement défendu je vous demande
pardon jérémy n'ont abandonné
cela ne faisait pas le poids et tacilier
avait dans son ventre
quelque chose qui lui pouvait tout son
temps sa force sa vie son attention et
son talent il faudra transmettre
l'intégralité de mon rapport au cabinet
monsieur voliez les conclusions
juridiques et puis aussi cette annexe
qui vous paraît intempestives
je souhaite que le taux atteignent le
président avant qu'ils les tuent à se
prononcer il sait jamais
[Musique]
où
et
[Applaudissements]
lui
[Musique]